[Music]
can blake shelton and gwen stefani get
any cuter
the lovebirds gave us all the feels
while performing their duet happy
anywhere at the academy of country music
awards on wednesday
here we are going into this thing with
with gwen and
i'm just having a blast right now the
evening marked gwen and blake's first
joint acm performance here we are we are
filming for
the academy of country music awards who
are you
my name is blake i get to be i get to be
on tv
and even though they couldn't physically
be in nashville where the award show
took place
they could have fooled us thanks to a
little tv magic
voila welcome back to the bluebird cafe
everybody
the country singer kicked off the duet
city light
southern stars no such thing is gone too
far with gwen quickly chiming in with
her powerful vocal chops
i was born with my feet in motion part
of what's great about gwen
is she's an incredible singer but the
other part that's appealing is she is
drop dead beautiful and wednesday
evening was
no exception the mom of three shared a
number of behind the scenes moments on
instagram
here we are we are on set yes we are
including several videos of her stunning
white denim ensemble
adorned with gold fringe and can we
talk about those gold thigh-high boots
the interesting thing on camera
okay visually it will be heard shelton
first announced that he and his leading
lady would be performing at the acm
earlier this month when he tweeted this
promo
the couple released happy anywhere back
in july
i feel like you know when you step into
launching a single together that's
that's the next step in our relationship
and while their music video will leave
you feeling
all warm and fuzzy the paris acm
performance was
filled with romance as they exchanged
loving glances and serenaded one another
and blake was sure to thank the lady in
his life when he won
single of the year for his song god's
country
thank you to the fans and thank you gwen
stefani for continuing to
encourage me to keep doing this and keep
trying and
being my inspiration also performing at
the event is shelton's ex-wife
miranda lambert we're going to do
bluebird right here at the bluebird
the 36 year old country crooner clearly
found the perfect venue
and the perfect outfit to deliver her
hit song
[Music]
following lambert's performance host
keith urban joined her on screen
to declare her winner of vocal event of
the year
making lambert the recipient of a
record-setting
35 acm awards that means miranda's won
more icms
than any human who's ever walked the
planet or venus apparently so that's
special i like that but it sounds better
when you're saying it like that it makes
a big deal